pal deux mois jour pour jour après la
mort du petit grégory ses parents ont
accepté de répondre aux questions notre
envoyé spécial isabelle bechler des
parents qui vivent ce drame avec
d'autant plus d'intensité que la presse
s'en est largement en parler vous le
savez bernard laroche le témoin numéro
un dans cette affaire est toujours en
prison
une incarcération sur la foi des
témoignages de la petite muriel mais
pour les parents de grégory
l'incarcération de la roche ne suffit
pas suffi pour inculper à rome si
shepard on veut savoir pourquoi et pour
qui la fait ça il ya beaucoup de choses
qui n'ont pas voté
qui dit que c'était fait quelqu'un le
produire de nom mais qu'on verra une
fois son ancien complice et une complice
ou via une femme qui sait qui c'est
parce que c'est une femme qui les
arrange et tout le monde est propre une
aile tout ça c'était toujours une fin
qui téléphonaient donc à ce moment il ya
une femme car liberté qui s'y qui sait
et cette femme vous n'avez pas d'idée de
qui ça peut être un peu partout réal ira
dessus on a dix qui file au juge
d'instruction matin s'agit de moi ma
femme l'a eu au bout du fil lui pour le
funèbre tout le garage médecins comme
ils ont toujours une fin qui la longe et
est lui à quatre et appelait après tout
fier de lui qu'on les envie pas une
surprise de taille le docteur août a eu
si tu as vu ça donc c'était bien une
mèche et si c'était pas bernard laroche
vous vous êtes sûr
une façon elle propre active
éternellement comme c'est un gardien
secret si monstrueux c'est pas normal
déjà de la part d'une vie de 15 ans sait
pas pourquoi que ça restera là
vous pensez que c'est la pression des
énormes de sa famille qui l'a fait se
rétracter sous que les joueurs la
compression la gendarmerie ni du juge
d'instruction c'est cependant moins là
que l'on aime répéter trois fois de
suite
elle a rien inventé il est hors normes
n'ont rien soufflé sa frappe mais
quelqu'un vienne joulaud te prends pas
éternellement comme ça c'est pas
possible il faut quand même admettre tel
témoignage de la isabelle qui dit quand
même que la muriel lui avais dit que je
l'avais vu bernard j'étais à saluer la
vologne
et ça quand même elle apparaît monter
sans parler du reste
jean-marie vous avez repris le travail
christine non vous êtes en train de
vendre cette maison vous avez vécu
comment est ce que vous imaginez
l'avenir très mal on dit bien que les
jeunes qu'il faut repartir à zéro
difficile
voilà ces résultats sont notamment pour
voir comment ça se déroule